[Music]
welcome to the reason Roundtable your
weekly libertarian podcast from the
magazine that has no plans to buy parlor
I am Matt Welch joined by Nicholas B
Peter souderman and a limping Catherine
rangu Ward Heidi Ho y'all
howdy hey Matt howdy howdy happy Monday
uh Catherine I was just down at uh
before we get started I was just down at
um a liberty con the annual conference
sort of annual conference depending on
the pandemic uh hosted by students for
Liberty uh and a lot of people are
expressing worry and anxiety about you
because you're unexpectedly absent due
to a horrific injury what happened
Catherine yeah
well so I was
I was uh on an e-scooter listening to
Justin amash's podcast
when I hit
foreign
pothole and fell and absolutely broke my
kneecap and now I can't walk or do
anything I am podcasting from my bed
yeah
yeah it hurts can you just if you're
retracing your steps uh where do you I
don't I have no steps now I have narious
where do you see the decision Matrix
breaking down is it like just being in
DC and thinking that riding scooters is
okay
you know I actually had an incredible
parenting moment about this which is
that um
I was uh explaining to my kids what
happened and they one of them said oh so
like the problem is that the government
didn't do a good job of Paving the road
and I was like yes that is the problem
if my roads had been private maybe I
would still have a kneecap
um it's a stretch but that's what you
know I'm I'm just working with what I
got here the uh
talking about this at Liberty con and we
will get to the podcast here in a moment
um with uh reason colleagues Robbie
Suave and Christian britsky
um uh now was making the usual uh
offensive cracks against people who ride
scooters in DC they then got to their
phones to show me all the damage they've
done to their face Robbie said something
like oh I've been hit by a car five
times
um it seems like you guys are doing
something wrong
they're so fun I will write again Matt I
will
uh have you ever written only
um only non-mechanized scooters back in
late 1970s California
um like the ones the little kids wear
now or well right now and it had tassels
red white and blue tassels coming from
the handlebars like a man USA uh all
right we're gonna get to uh talking
about voters stubborn refusal to
prioritize what Democrats in the media
want them to
but first oh that was loud a word from
our sponsor donor's trust the
tax-friendly way to simplify your
charitable giving without compromising
your values friends is cancel culture
coming for your charitable giving big
banks are increasingly reluctant to
allow charitable savings accounts or
Donor advised funds as they're formerly
called to direct money toward
libertarian or conservative non-profits
the list of Charities that have been
recently rejected by big Banks include
the atlas Network National Review
Institute the National Rifle Association
Foundation Liberty Council and others to
help ensure that your dollars support
your values
come to donors trust donors trust is
built to serve people who want to put
money behind their beliefs limited
government and constitutional rights to
learn more download a prospectus at
www.onorstrust.org reason
if you already have a Donor advised fund
please consider opening a rollover
account that's
www.downorstrust.org reason align your
giving with your values visit
donorstrust.org today
you'll be glad you did okay it's uh not
just the waft of pumpkin spice in the
air no that pungent Aroma is the smell
of flop sweat coming from Democrats with
three short weeks between now and the
Congressional midterm elections here's a
fresh headline from this morning's New
York Times
Republicans gain Edge as voters worry
about economy times Sienna pole fines
with elections next month Independents
especially women
are swinging to the GOP despite
Democrats focus on abortion rights
disapprove of President Biden seems to
be hurting his party end quote or as a
more caustic headline writer might put
it this just in midterms are mid-term
sing uh there's been a bunch of polls
out the past few days including an
interesting Harvard Harris survey that
can be crudely summarized as saying
voters priorities are not the same as
msnbc's Catherine
in grabbing the interesting pole nugget
of your choice and perhaps maybe
um just tell us your level of enthusiasm
preemptively as people get ready to
blame the ladies once again for enabling
fascisms oh I didn't know I was going to
get the lady question right up top here
yeah well I mean no it's fair it's fair
um so think that you know I'm always
torn on these poor results because on
the one hand I love to have voters just
generally be mad at whoever is currently
in power because they are right to be
mad at whoever is currently in power on
the other hand it is not going to be a
solution to put this other batch of
idiots in power like Republicans are not
going to fix inflation Republicans are
not going to make your pumpkin spice
coffee cheaper and uh they don't have
the power to do that for the most part
now of course policy matters um and I
did I would say the tidbit I liked the
best from this poll
was the fact that um all of the Biden
kind of stimulus payments support
payments inflation offset payments all
of those all of those payments are not
polling well people are not saying like
ah yeah that's really what I needed in
this moment so they are both not
electorally helpful for the people doing
them and our counterproductive
economically that's a that's a real win
great work everybody but yeah I I think
I don't think this is going to be a
blame the ladies cycle do you I think I
think it's going to be I mean we're
white women are bad I guess but but I
think that this is definitely going to
be much more of a like very very classic
the economy is bad the party in power is
in trouble and as you say midterms are
midterm thing this is uh uh the
preemptive blame the ladies thing here's
a bit of a verbiage in the New York
Times piece from today uh the biggest
shift came from women who identified as
independent voters in September they
favor Democrats by 14 points now
Independent Women backed Republicans by
18 points
so like we're mad about abortion and now
we're mad about inflation yeah and we're
right to be mad about both those things
so screw you on uh Peter you brought the
Harvard Harris poll to our attention
thank you very much for that what
interested you there
so in that poll and in the New York
Times poll I think what you're seeing is
a weird kind of weird but also in some
ways predictable repeat of 1970s
inflation politics and so I spent a
couple of months earlier this year
working on a big piece for the magazine
about the the ways in which we are not
exactly repeating the politics and
policy mistakes of uh of the 1970s but
it does feel like we're in some kind of
like trance synthwave remix of them
right like it's like the same stuff just
in a different order and with a slightly
different Beach I mean there's inflation
and oil shocks there's a foreign policy
crisis or maybe several of them Global
disarray there's this sense that that
crime is a real problem big liberal
cities are a mess uh if you remember
that dark weird speech that Biden gave
where it looked like he was kind of
addressing you know the first order like
the empire in Star Wars the whole thing
was gloomy and kind of inexplicable and
people people were like why why is he
doing this right it was It was kind of
sort of a version of the malays speech
it was like Hey America we're in a dark
place the malays speech which notably
did not ever actually use the word
malaise but the other thing you see
looking at the 1970s in the politics of
the 1970s the economy of the 1970s uh
that is just really really apparent this
morning in particular is that voters
really really really do not like
inflation and I if you go back to the
the polling on on issues and the debates
that were happening between Carter and
Reagan or the one debate between Carter
and Reagan before the 1980 election it
was just Far and Away the number one
issue going into the 1980 presidential
election voters were really mad about
inflation and then like Beyond inflation
they would be like well I'm also mad
about the economy and about energy and
you know what those are those are kind
of all the same thing uh and when it's
when inflation is high it's just very
difficult for incumbent politicians to
deflect or shift blame and that's what
Carter tried to do what Biden has tried
you know to do as well he's blamed
Putin's price hikes the pandemic
everything but Biden's policies and
political leadership and the reason that
politicians can't deflect blame is
because Rising prices are so plain to
see gas and food prices in particular
are just incredibly visible on something
like a daily basis to so many voters and
I think that when people go to the polls
in November more than anything else
Maybe not maybe that's not the only
issue that they're going to be voting on
but in some ways inflation kind of
captures all of the other issues it's
the one data point and that's what is
going to is going to decide this
election more than any other single
thing Nick what do you see in those uh
polls out there that is of particular
interest to you so uh in the the cap
hair or Harvard cap Harris poll one
thing that I I found most interesting is
less political but they ask people what
are the most favorable Institute or what
institutions you have the most favorable
opinions of and the top three by a lot
are the U.S military Amazon and the
police and
that in itself kind of suggests that
like where people are and where the
media is are very Divergent
um and which then has ramifications for
a lot of coverage and a lot of the stuff
that uh both uh Catherine Peter were
alluding to the other thing and this is
um from a summary of polls for ballot
from balapedia Trump and Biden basically
have the same unfavorable ratings or
favorable ratings as uh as the other had
at this time in their presidency but the
difference was when in 2018 something
like 40 percent of Americans thought the
country was going in the right direction
now it's down to like 24 according to
their averaging and that's a huge shift
because if uh you know political
scientists have have mapped the first
term midterms for the president's party
if the president is under 50 approval
the average loss in the house is
something like or the median loss is
like 37 seats this is shaping up to be a
really really bad house uh outcome for
the Democrats uh the Senate it's more
interesting because the Republicans
really in a lot of kind of walk over
states where they should have been able
to win easily really have gone out of
their way to nominate just complete
dum-dums so we'll see but it's not
looking good for uh the Democrats it's
really notable how much Democrats have
just abdicated all of the economic
issues to the Republican Party they're
not talking about them or to the extent
they are it's like I said it's it's
Biden just blaming somebody else for
problems or sort of saying well look at
the the you know unemployment rate which
is uh which is quite low but if you look
at this poll the top five issues are
number one is inflation number two is
economy and jobs number three is
immigration number four is crime and
drugs and number five is women's rights
the first four of those are regardless
of what we think you know about
Republicans and immigration
um you know or or Republicans in crime
the first four of those are all issues
that give Republicans an advantage and
that Republicans have been playing up
very heavily in advance of the vote hey
Peter in your research about inflation
politics in the 1980 presidential race
did Reagan specifically say what he
would do to combat inflation or did he
merely are you know kind of say that he
would fix it
um because one of the things I I agree
with you know Biden has he's tried to
blame everything else but he's also
never said what he is going to do to fix
it other than kind of say like I'm going
to give people a lot of money and I
think most people understand that that's
not going to fix the problem that is the
problem but did Reagan specifically say
you know I'm going to cut spending and
you know push to increase you know
interest rates while cutting taxes or
did he just kind of say I would control
things better than uh a mix of the two
somewhere in between I would say so he
had an inflation plan that was an
economic plan that was built around uh
tax cuts it was the numbers were
honestly kind of dubious when you
actually looked into how the plan worked
out it was it was however something
sort of specific
but then in when he was on the campaign
Trail and in particular when he was
debating Carter Carter would say well
look you know they're all of these
headwinds facing the country uh we have
you know in particular we've got um
global economic shocks that are just
really messing with the price of oil
that sort of thing and he would you know
sort of say other you know well there
are other problems too we basically say
the thing that you can't say as
president even if it's kind of true
which is this isn't really my fault and
Reagan turned that around on him and
Reagan just delivered this uh it quite
effective again I don't think perfectly
accurate I could like quibble with a
bunch of the things he said but
incredibly effective response to Carter
when they when added on inflation where
he basically said you have blamed just
about everything else you've blamed the
Federal Reserve you've blamed you know
Saudi Arabia and oil Shucks you've
blamed uh Republicans you've blamed just
what you have done what you've haven't
done is blame the government for it the
government itself and your policies and
his and Reagan's sort of summarize um I
don't have the quote right in front of
me but what he came in sort of he
finished this bit by saying the problem
is that the government has been living
too large
and that that has made it hard for the
people to live well
and it was again we could certainly
quibble with the specifics I don't think
that the inflation plan the economic
plan that he put forward is you know
just like it was a
was unimpeachable at the same time
what what he did was he turned around
the question and said you can't blame
everybody else you have to take
responsibility for this and my my answer
is don't make government the center of
the solution Catherine um I want to
invite you to react to a couple of
quotes from our president uh Joseph
Robinette Biden Jr and you know in light
of the accusation here from our
colleagues that he hasn't really been
saying much of anything about about the
economy inflation so first one comes
from a stop at a Baskin Robbins in
Portland Oregon
our economy is strong as hell
that's the first one and then the second
one is a uh is a tweet uh from Sunday
that's thank you that's such a good
impersonation uh real American genius um
second one is a tweet uh from Sunday if
republicans in Congress get their way
prices will go up and inflation will get
worse and then a couple little carriage
return spaces and then at the bottom
it's that simple it it is not it is not
that simple our economy is not strong as
hell and it is not that simple I don't
know he seems wrong uh the thing about
these like off the cuff Biden quotes is
that they are almost indistinguishable
from carefully crafted Biden quotes like
that's the thing that always blows my
mind is like the dark Biden speech that
suitorman was referring to earlier had
lines of equal poignancy and craft you
know I mean it was just still absolutely
like I will just assert stuff and you
know what this reminds me of frankly is
Donald Trump who also would just like
say things not back them up maybe not
fully finish the sentence and then just
hope for the best
um it's like he was on a podcast all the
time it was like he was on a podcast all
the time I mean we do that here but like
we're not the president of the United
States for crying out loud
uh Nick you were talking a little bit
about the gap between uh media and voter
concerns
I'll flip that a little bit like one of
the things media is obsessed with
um and uh that we we frankly haven't
talked about it as much as maybe as we
could have or the January 6th uh
hearings right um every day there's a
new thing about uh this number of
Republicans half I think roughly that
are campaigning in midterms or for
whatever offices are uh what a media
frequently calls election deniers and
you know every time you turn on CNN or
MSNBC you're going to hear the words
January 6th and Insurrection within the
first 10 seconds and that's clearly not
front of mine among most voters
um but is there an argument and you know
something like immigration is on the
other hand uh is there an argument to be
made like well
well it should be more front of mind and
we're just doing our jobs to try to tell
people what the important issues are
Matt I would love to answer that
question but I'm still waiting on the
final or actually the first invest
investigation of what happened in
Benghazi
um
and to be honest January 6 is a lot like
Benghazi where for the people who are
into it it is all that matters and the
people who are insisting that this is
you know the the this Rosetta Stone of
all the perfidy of the previous
administration for a thousand years uh
they're just writing themselves out of
um relevance to uh to most Americans uh
January 6 was [ __ ] up it was stupid
Trump Bears some responsibility uh it
was not an Insurrection it didn't work
the system held Etc Trump shouldn't run
for office again he shouldn't be
president the Republicans shouldn't do
that all you can say all of that stuff
nothing is going to come out of that
that is going to you know change make it
more important to people
um I think and and to your larger point
it's just that the media
um you know and particular subsets of
the media are obsessed with it because
that's where they are but it's not where
people are
I mean we've talked about this before
this is January 6 continues to be the
basket in which you know a certain a
certain type of commentator and a
certain type of voter has kind of put
all the eggs of like people are going to
realize that Trump is really bad and we
just have to keep talking about this and
they're going to realize that this is
bad and it was really bad I will say
like January 6 was worse than Benghazi
definitely in my view but we don't need
to we don't need to do that ranking for
the most part because neither of those
things are going to make a dent in the
views that the other side has about the
main character there all right let's
shift gears a little bit there's a lot
of Social Media stuff in the news we
like to talk about it here on this
podcast uh there's reporting from The
Wall Street Journal uh just today that
the insanely talented and perhaps
talentedly insane uh rapper entrepreneur
and anti-semitic conspiracy theorizer
Kanye West is set to buy the
freewheeling platform parlor
which fun fact is owned by the husband
of conservative grifter Candace Owens
who's been piling around with Kanye West
uh where the two of them wearing
matching White lives Matter t-shirts and
yes every single word I just said in the
previous sentences would have been
completely indecipherable to me 10 years
ago all this comes in the heels of news
last week which we covered a lot of
Reason uh from the internet 1.0 uh money
service PayPal
he announced that they were going to
start deducting uh 2500 fines uh from
users who were deemed by PayPal uh to be
spreading quote unquote misinformation
after an outcry including from the
foundation for individual rights and
expression
they rebranded uh the online payments
Processing Company backtracked somewhat
saying well we're only going to find you
and deduct from your accounts if you do
intolerance
um Peter to uh paraphrase uh the Talking
Heads what the hell is going on uh with
social media and is this all just an
expression of the beautiful Marketplace
of private censorship that you've been
advocating all along
I mean after all the things we've been
through I mean after all the things we
got into I know some things that you
ain't told me I did some things but
that's the old me
wow that happened huh
yeah so that's uh that's Kanye West over
a decade ago in uh the great song
heartless on what is probably my
favorite Kanye West album 808s and
heartbreak massively underrated maybe
not his actual best but my favorite I
don't know man I don't what is what what
opinion are we supposed to have about my
opinion about Kanye West is always and
forever give me a new album that's it
um the question was about social media
uh Peter I was wondering if you could
reflect on that but he's right so Kanye
West wants to buy a social media company
Elon Elon Musk is buying Twitter uh this
this if nothing else this shows us that
these things aren't uh that uh are that
the the arrangement of social media
power uh is not stable right and so we
have spent the last decade or so having
debates in Congress sometimes and
certainly sort of major parts of our
political and cultural discourse about
whether Facebook and Twitter are like so
big that they will never ever uh you
know sort of be dislodged from their
positions and look Facebook is like
flailing into the metaverse Mark
Zuckerberg is really really happy that
he added the legs this is this is I'm
not making this up there was like a hole
day-long press conference I do yes
Catherine this is for you Mark
Zuckerberg has solved your problem
Catherine which is that your avatar
needs function legs and Mark Zuckerberg
is like here functional legs thanks
buddy this is this just ridiculous this
whole this app this whole thing this the
the political debate we have been having
about how these things are monopolies
about how they should basically be you
know sort of uh Public Utilities
quasi-arms of the government that like
Elizabeth Warren and Josh Hawley should
get together to decide exactly which
posts or misinformation disinformation
or either just sort of bad speech that
they don't like about whether these
things should be subsidized owned by the
federal government nationalized whatever
it is it's all dumb it's all dumb
because someday Elon Musk or Kanye West
is going to wake up and think ah maybe
I'll just buy one and then what's gonna
happen after that we don't know we have
no idea at all and that's how the market
works is we don't know how it will
evolve we just know that it will and so
any theory of of uh any industry but
especially one that is so important as
as the speech industry as the uh as the
allowing people to say things online
industry any industry like any theory of
that industry that says actually we've
we've hit the the final form of it right
this is the end of social media history
and nothing will ever come after this
that theory is always wrong nick uh
first it would commend uh uh listeners
to go check out your great talk with Eli
Lake about uh all things Kanye
um I want to play our every podcast uh
Matt and Nick talk about do you remember
when uh or I'm old enough to remember
when
[Music]
we are old enough to remember when
PayPal was a super libertarian
newfangled alternative to all them
fuddy-duddy payments processing system
and who remind me Matt who uh who are
the two big wigs of PayPal it was Peter
Thiel
and then some other dude some kind of
rusky whatever happened to him
yeah uh can you just sort of reflect on
that uh as like a a symbol of how many
institutions including you know online
only institutions have just absolutely
devolved from their original purpose in
ethos
yeah you know another one uh that came
up around the same time was Skype uh
which was going to revolutionize and
empower the world uh with free audio uh
free video calls uh which it kind of did
but the guys who created Skype uh were
Swedish originally they moved to Estonia
but they um you know they they uh put
out a Manifesto about how this was going
to change the world Skype is now owned
by Microsoft
um so not quite and you know it has
gotten its ass kicked by zoom and a
couple of other things but I kind of
missed that era you know when PayPal was
going to bring you know it was going to
be a new form of e-commerce that was
going to you know it had a lot of it it
was kind of had a lot of whiff of
Bitcoin pre-bitcoin
um but it's not that way anymore I want
to introduce into uh the conversation
just the concept of what uh Rob long who
some of us know he uh does a lot of
podcasts he was the head he was the
showrunner cheers for uh a while writes
for National Review and commentary in
other places but he was telling me
recently that um you know the ambulatory
psychotics uh that we see walking around
the streets of cities like New York LA
and San Francisco Howard not have now
jumped to the highest levels of power
and he's talking about like Trump Biden
and Kanye West
that they are ambulatory psychotics and
like he's not sure whether this is like
the ultimate Triumph of the disabled or
a sign that we're going down the drain
but I like the phrase ambulances that's
uh that's that's a keeper uh Catherine
um for changing I'm going to read you a
tweet
um this one comes from
thanks official uh Twitter account of
the house Judiciary GOP
okay
um so the the GOP Republican Party House
Judiciary uh your committee uh this is
from October 6th so pretty recent and
it's still up there
three words each with a period at the
end ready
Kanye
period
Elon
period
Trump
period
how do you respond
what the [ __ ]
first of all Great lead dramatic opener
I like it uh not sure that that level of
literary achievement has previously been
seen in that venue
um right so I think there's this always
always there's this weird thing in this
conversation where it's like
members of Congress are like here's the
thing we're really worried about a small
number of weirdos having a lot of
control over things and it's like my
guys it's you like it's literally you I
don't like I just don't understand how
straight-facedly you could make this
argument like an elite cabal of unusual
characters is gonna be in charge of what
people can think or do or say like it's
you the call is coming from inside the
house but they're a duly elected by up
to 25 of the people they claim to
represent this morning mad about
inflation are gonna choose them so I
guess it's fine like I so there's that
there's just like my basic you know uh
if your worry is Elite control like
Congress is not the place to solve that
but also you know I do I do think though
I actually remain fairly staunchly in
the you know the The Winds of creative
destruction are going to continue to
sweep through the social media sector
and we're gonna be fine I do think there
is there is a possibility for a bad
equilibrium here that we should be
trying to avoid and that is one in which
we have de facto control over what
speech is or isn't allowed but it is
done through the mechanism of the
decision makers at social media
companies either trying to guess what
the politically powerful want them to do
or being told informally by the
politically powerful what to do who's
allowed to speak uh on what terms
they're allowed to speak and that all
happens sort of one layer of remove from
where anyone can see it either
shareholders or the voting public and I
I think that that is a concern uh and I
think this is like a classic example of
a place where
we're sort of Crossing into maybe a
newish form of cronyism like it's a
newish form of kind of collaboration
between big business and big government
in a way that does harm consumers I
think there are a couple ways out of it
one is just to you know to demand that
they're you know that users demand more
transparency and I think that that is
already happening you know people can
defect from products that they don't
like regardless of their knowledge about
where exactly the sources of those bad
decisions come from and then also that
we should you know ideally be electing
public officials who don't think that
it's their business to sort of pressure
or ultimately coerce
um social media companies about what you
know what they're supposed to do but I
think there is a there is a kind of
um temporary probably unstable but
nonetheless pernicious equilibrium that
we seem to be headed towards and I I
would like to avoid it
um I don't exactly know how your your
press release that you just read There
is going to help with that problem
um because the more that these
individuals who own social media
companies or who have big decision
making power and social media companies
feel targeted
um you know they're going to break
different ways like some of them are
going to break Jack and be like screw
you guys I do what I want and then
retire and some of them are gonna give
in for the sake of maintaining the
viability of their commercial Enterprise
I would uh add before we leave the topic
uh commend people to check out a report
by the Cato Institute
um uh a week or two ago about uh what
they call jaw boning where the federal
government various agencies or
politicians uh go after uh try to
breathe heavily on uh social media
companies and other people to try to
de-platform various people including uh
pretty famously Alex Berenson the uh
kind of uh covid skeptic
um uh it was kicked off Twitter in other
places uh both Jacob Solomon Robbie
Suave wrote about this a lot uh and it
is an increasing and still kind of too
little probably a discussed factor in
our political life right now governments
telling people to kick people off their
platforms it's bad they shouldn't do
that all right we're gonna get to our
listener email of the week here
momentarily
but first
a word from our sponsor betterhelp
friends when you're weary feeling small
depressed by the ever shrinking days
overwhelmed by all that life is throwing
at you do you focus more on the problem
or on the solution stressful situations
often produce fight-or-flight reactions
but that's no way to get through every
day in this thing called life we need
instead to train our brains into
becoming problem-solving machines that
is where betterhelp.com comes in
betterhelp is customizable online
therapy super convenient and affordable
and ready right now to set you up with a
professional counselor to help organize
your Noggin to become an organ that
assists rather than a system that
overloads here's what you do go to
betterhelp.com Roundtable fill out a
brief questionnaire match up with a
licensed therapist and you'll already
get 10 off your first month don't like
your first match you can get another and
so on and so on that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash Roundtable go there
today you'll be glad you did okay
reminder end and send whatever lend men
to your queries to Roundtable ad
reason.com
this one comes from JD Brennan in
Seattle
he writes Noah Smith makes an
interesting case which he links below
that the tarp bailouts that's the
troubled asset relief program see I
remember that bailouts avoided a second
Great Depression what say you Roundtable
Catherine
I don't know I guess we give those guys
a Nobel Prize so that's something
um yeah I like this actually is a really
hard question because
um everyone who's smarter than me on
this stuff seems to think that that
sentence is kind of true which is
interesting to me like I take that
seriously when there's broad consensus
about this sort of thing
um my
um you know
my question is just always what is the
long-term consequence I think that you
can both have saved the world from a
great depression and maybe uh in the
long run have done
serious damage that has yet to be fully
appreciated but that's me taking refuge
in first principles at like a very uh
cowardly level and I don't have a great
answer to this question today nicolespie
what's your answer uh no I don't think
uh the the choices are in between a
second Great Depression or the policy
was perfect or something like that and
there's no question that the tarp
program did not uh you know it didn't
Target the activity that it was intended
to do it didn't necessarily save a lot
of businesses it almost certainly
hampered the recovery
um so I think that it I think that's
wrong you know the government did a lot
of different things we didn't have the
decline we didn't have the depression
that we had in the 30s for a wide
variety of different reasons including
the I you know the fact that
[Music]
um
National currencies are much more length
they're based against each other and
things like that the economy is very
different so no Peter you are both a
tarp critic and obviously a DC statist
what's your answer so I think there were
a lot of mistakes made in response to
the Great Recession and the biggest to
my mind was uh was actually Aura the the
Obama stimulus the fiscal uh policy
response which is just really badly
targeted all throughout at very best I
think you can make a case that tarp
worked in a narrow sense and on its own
terms that by injecting liquidity into
the banking system it kept the banking
system from Total collapse from uh from
sort of failures spreading from One bank
to another and that unlike the Obama
fiscal stimulus which was very expensive
the cost of taxpayers was basically zero
because the money was all repaid even if
you can argue about exactly whether the
the rates that it was repaid at should
have been higher some of this sort of
thing but
I would say to that case
um I have a couple of responses first is
that counterfactuals are just hard
inherently difficult we just don't know
what would have happened in the absence
of tarp second is that there are serious
legal and sort of
executive branch Authority questions
about tarp this was at minimum of an
extremely novel policy it was put
together in like just a couple of days
gave treasury the treasury Department a
kind of unlimited power with not a whole
lot of oversight and that created its
own problems so again not a when I say
not a whole lot of oversight I don't
mean zero but it wasn't like there were
sort of folks from Congress in there you
know watching over day-to-day decisions
and so there were congressional
oversight reports that were released and
I I want to be clear this is not like
the Republican congressional oversight
uh reports right Elizabeth Warren was a
channel was a panel member and I was
looking at some of the reports
um over the last day you know in
response to this reader's question and
the second one starts pretty much from
the beginning and it just says the panel
still does not know what the banks are
doing with taxpayer money
that's Elizabeth Warren and Jeb
henserling together saying we have no
idea what treasury is doing with
hundreds of billions of dollars treasury
places substantial emphasis in its
letter of uh from December um on the
importance of restoring confidence in
the marketplace but so long as investors
and customers are uncertain about how
taxpayer funds are being used the
question uh they question both the
health and sound management of all
financial institutions so
it was a plan to give the treasury all
the power and hope that worked now maybe
maybe you can say that it worked in this
one case that Ben Bernanke had studied
the Great Depression and that we we got
lucky because there was a guy who
actually really knew what he was doing
there for once do we think that that's a
sustainable plan going forward do we
have maybe one or two other examples of
that sort of plan going badly so I think
at minimum it was sold poorly it didn't
really help ordinary homeowners and it
set a bad precedent because even if you
accept that it worked this one time it
created really terrible incentives
because it was with the reason it really
didn't help ordinary homeowners was at
heart it was a bailout for banks
and what it basically said was hey Banks
if you get big enough that you're that
your continued operations are we
consider them sort of uh like deeply
integral to the functioning of the U.S
macro economy then if you're ever like
if it ever looks like maybe you're gonna
fail the US government is going to step
in and make sure that you don't that is
a very bad incentive going forward I'd
like to
um provide a little bit of a context
that sometimes uh gets lost as people
um present this as a uh either prevent
the Great Depression or not this is what
George W bush then president Believe It
or Not uh said in September 2008 I
forget whether this is right before the
first vote on tarp or before the second
but at any rate
um uh people were panicking in
Washington people like Michael Bloomberg
were saying it doesn't matter what we do
we just need to do something
uh et cetera Etc confidence this was a
you know a widely respected respected
opinion that David Brooks is the world
we're all saying it doesn't matter we
just need to do something here's what
George W bush said what would happen if
we did not pass tarp
more Banks could fail including some in
your community the stock market would
drop even more which would reduce the
value of your retirement account the
value of your home could plummet
foreclosures would rise dramatically and
if you own a business or reform you
would find it harder and more expensive
to get credit
more businesses would close their doors
and millions of Americans could lose
their jobs even if you have good credit
history it would be more difficult for
you to get the loans you need to buy a
car or send your children to college and
ultimately our country could experience
a long and painful recession
all of that happened
all of the things that we needed to pass
tarp to prevent because it wasn't we're
going to have another Great Depression
it was we're going to have that that I'm
pointing at my computer that I just read
to you
um we did have all of that in direct
answer to the listener's question like
Catherine I don't know
um I it's the the counterfactual is
impossible to do but I can tell you what
uh many people including at reason and
very thoughtful and detailed ways at the
moment struggling with the world going
crazy all around
um predicted would happen if you would
do this uh predicted that you'd be
creating moral hazard that's true uh
predicted that such amounts of of uh
government spending would uh eventually
cause or sooner rather than later
because the government's grow so high
that it would put a drag on long-term
growth we'd go from the two to three
percent that we'd enjoyed for decades to
more like one to two percent that's huge
difference that all turned out to be
true a whole bunch of of negative side
effects including
um after a brief blip of uh austerity
politics in the Tea Party wave including
um that uh there's basically you had
blown to Smithereens any sense of
restraints on uh federal spending which
we have
um if we're being very honest about it
that's gone
um uh we created authorities uh just
random out of thin air like oh tarp
means that we can take over the car
industry sure
um even though they specifically uh
tried to pass a bill doing that and it
was voted down so those kinds of
authorities and sense that the federal
government could do anything it wants in
a moment of Crisis hmm has that come up
since
um yes it has a couple of times a couple
of times we've had during the pandemic
although it's worth pointing out a
thousand times for some reason
was it the CDC I I'm still I can't
believe it um was telling people that
they can't
um kick people out if they don't pay
their rent Catherine talk over me please
I would be delighted to
um no I was just gonna say I think there
is a counter counter factual I guess
where we would have gotten to that place
whether or not tarpet happened that is
the the kind of factors that contributed
to our politicians and our political
culture being ripe for the
overreach essentially that tarp was
if we hadn't done it then we would have
done it in the next Crisis
um that's a very dark vision I suppose
from a Libertarian perspective but that
basically we were we were already as a
country in a place where we were
we were one crisis away from just
letting loose you know infinite spending
essentially infinite emergency powers
and that we had already done that in
many areas including National Security
and so this was just a natural next step
and tarp happened to be it but it would
have been something
um and that that still puts us in this
same bad place but doesn't necessarily
mean that
um you know tarp was what Uncorked it
one thing to also watch which we did in
real time at reason as well is that
um Barack Obama after becoming president
and look at the his speech craft in
um early 2009 over and over again uh he
would keep saying uh things like uh you
know when I took office we were the
entire Global Financial system was on
the verge of a meltdown
um it's not true he took office in
January of 2009 meltdown to the extent
of which it was hanging over everyone's
head was in the fall of 2008 it seems
like that's uh splitting hairs it's not
because he used that to pass the
aforementioned uh stimulus
um and uh and also to to look backwards
and bathe in a holy glow the decisions
that his administration took or the ones
that they kept from the Bush
Administration preceding and make it
seem like it was more Dynamic dramatic
uh at the time than it actually was in
real time
um the banks weren't melting down in
March of 2009 uh in April 2009 so when
people use the framing of we avoided the
great a Great Depression 2.0
that really wasn't the stakes being set
out at the time so watch it when people
are are kind of uh retrofitting uh the
stakes of a crisis uh backwards
um they might be right I'm open up to
that possibility uh but they're also
rewriting what the stakes felt like at
the time
it's worth pointing out all right uh
very briefly uh before we get to our end
of podcast cultural recommendations uh I
just wanted to highlight the fact that
today October 10th no it's October 10th
17th one of these days who knows if I
don't have my Google Calendar in front
of me Nick I just it's really hard to uh
anyways it's the anniversary of the
authorization of the use of military
force in Iraq 20th anniversary in 2002
um which was a mistake
um at the time we shouldn't have used
military first shouldn't have authorized
it
um and led uh that's the legal uh
justification for the Iraq War uh all
that terrible mistake um and uh also it
should be repealed and there's more
movement afoot uh in the house and the
Senate to repeal it instead of keeping
an open-ended authorization uh for Force
that's used in all kinds of matters that
have zilcho to do with its original
intent
um all aumfs there's still ones in the
books from Eisenhower Administration I
think it's like
1957. there's like an open-ended one
because we were worried about like
communism in the Middle East
um we still kind of can use
um there are Barbara Lee has some Peter
Meyer has some uh various uh
bills out there to repeal these aumfs
some Rand Paul's been in favor of that
should be done Congress should do that
that's my editorial for today all right
let's go to our uh end of podcast what
we have been uh consuming the cultural
Arena Catherine uh besides pain killing
drugs what have you been consuming you
know I'm going to just go all in and say
uh the Justin amosh podcast
dude when I went ass over tea kettle it
was not Justin amasha's it's so good it
hurts would you say it's so good it
hurts I was listening episode actually
which was very good because I was meant
to be interviewing Amash about the ways
in which Congress is broken
um at Fuller is a congressional reporter
I thought hey I missed this one I'll
listen to this one so
um but in preparation for this interview
I was listening to several of them and
it's a good podcast guys if you like
this podcast you are almost certainly
gonna like that one
um and uh you know this of course Justin
Amash always and forever represents the
greatest challenge to my uh my deep
belief that all politicians are garbage
and will disappoint you in the end
um I sort of can't help but remain
hopeful that uh that Justin amasha's
story will come out with the happiest of
endings uh in which she becomes I don't
know president of the United States
failing that though he has a pretty good
podcast and you should listen to it
um but I mostly want to put a request
here
um I I'm gonna have some free time to
consume some media
and I would love recommendations from uh
from podcast listeners uh you know I
sometimes get these anyway and I'm
always super super grateful for them
um but I I need them now more than ever
my one plan is to consume absolutely
everything in the expanse series both
books and
um the show but suiterman has already
talked enough about those and so I will
not talk about that much on this podcast
other recommendations would be
um very welcome especially something
that's like a little bit funny I would
like some some funny thank you
I recommend Catherine that you can start
at any time in your life you start
listening to music music is great no
deal it's art for the ears
thank you for that very insightful
analysis Matt you want me for music
there's a there's a backstory to that
well I'll tell you something involving
communism Catherine were you fiddling
with your phone when you uh or why are
you trying to blame you've been
distracted while you were no I mean I
was distracted
tones I guess but no I was I it was a
little bit uh it was a little bit damp
out
and uh and so maybe
um we can blame puddles but we cannot
blame my phone
uh Nick what have you been consuming uh
so you mentioned Eisenhower at least
once today Matt but I uh consume this
great uh exhibition in a coffee shop in
uh in New York near Thompson Square Park
9th Street espresso uh which bizarrely
is on the intersection of 10th Street
and Avenue B but it's called 20th
century artifacts from another timeline
by an artist named John tabou and
there'll be a link where you can see it
in Instagram but basically uh what the
guy does is he imagines a different
timeline from the one we are uh in where
in the late 50s when um Eisenhower had a
heart attack
um as a result his doctor you know takes
care of him and then uh suggests that he
take LSD in order to kind of calm his
anxiety about death after that and then
there's an alternative timeline
including where he uh he doses Richard
Nixon as well who becomes president in
60 because he's no longer like a bitter
horrible man and and things just go off
in a different direction uh it's very
funny it's very clever I disagree with
some of you know the the places where
John who I know slightly uh wants to go
with things but it's really great and
it's an imaginative exercise in you know
imagining an alternative future which is
in fact a way of event or you know in a
met imagining an alternative present
which is a way of imagining a
alternative future Matt you'll like this
in particular uh you know LSD in the
1950s particularly was used heavily to
treat alcoholism and one of the subtexts
of this series is that Mickey Mantle
takes LSD in the 50s and ends up having
like a 35-year career as a result and
ends up with the Houston Astros yeah um
in like the 70s so it's it's it's a very
inventive very funny very clever and I
think very uh you know low-key inspiring
uh kind of way to think about stuff and
it it overlapped with the horizons
conference which is the oldest and
longest running uh psychedelic
conference
um that it's been going on for about 15
years where
um business people are interested in
this researchers and then culture
critics and whatnot all get together in
New York in the fall so 20th century
artifacts from another timeline by John
Tebow it's really clever funny and
inspiring it sounds like a one of my
favorite uh uh painting exhibitions I've
ever attended about 20 years ago in LA
and I forget the guy's name I'll look it
up
um but uh it was uh scenes included
really large like uh uh very uh active
paintings about the war between Northern
California and Southern California yeah
yeah um and it's just it's fantastic and
and it breaks your brain in a lot of
different ways so shift if I may just
quickly in New York work and I think I
did this two weeks ago uh Wonderland
dreams which was an immersive art
project this is kind of like that I mean
it's much more interactive than a
typical kind of art thing and there's a
shift going on I think it's particularly
intensified post covid of making art
much more of an interactive process and
whatnot and I think that's all to the
good because that's how we should be
consuming all art anyway
um but you know this this kind of
um uh turn really foregrounds the
creation of meaning and possibility and
kind of inspiration for Martin so more
power to it Peter what have you been
consuming I watched werewolf By Night a
Marvel Comics Special on Disney plus so
uh comic book guys out there I know
there are some in our audience uh we'll
remember one shots uh which is a just
single issue stories not really
connected to anything else they're kind
of out there often out of uh the
continuity or sort of not directly
related to the sort of Mainline
continuity of a comic book or a
character the kind of fun little
footnotes or side quests typically small
ball stories not big epics but there
were often some of the most fun things
that Marvel released as a result because
they didn't bear the weight of the you
know sort of the mainline story and that
is what werewolf by night is it's a
50-minute Marvel Comics one shot in TV
movie form it's in black and white now
they originally shot it in color and
like made it black and white afterwards
and added digital grain so it looks kind
of goofy but it's kind of a tribute to
the William Castle School of cheesy
lucky horror films and it's it's just
really fun right so the story is a bunch
of Monster Hunters gather together to
hunt a monster with the Bloodstone and
there's an appearance by man thing you
know who also known as giant-sized man
thing although in this case they only
refer to him as Ted
because that's he's not called man thing
at all in the the show and it's just
it's sort of amusing and silly and it
doesn't take itself seriously but also
isn't like a a self-aware parody of this
sort of thing either it's there's just
the right amount of comic book werewolf
monster movie schlocky earnestness you
know for a werewolf movie it gets kind
of hairy inevitably but it's pretty good
um so I'm gonna make uh Catherine feel
even worse
um I saw one of the most moving pieces
of art
um that I I've seen in a long time
um and it's also something that uh the
vast majority of people listening will
have zero access to so I'm now
exercising my libertarian privilege
um which is to say uh while I was down
in Florida I traveled to the house
of American hero Bob Poole reasons
long-standing uh savior uh
Transportation policy uh Chieftain uh
and so forth uh lives over in Fort
Lauderdale I'm not gonna give his
address yet
um but Bob has been known uh over the
years to have an elaborate
model railroad set of his own design
um and I'd heard about this I'd heard
tell Whispers
um but he and uh his now wife Lou
um they were contractual arrangement for
a long time
um
uh invited me to their house and uh and
after uh appropriate proceedings um and
you know I was made to follow the rules
about what happens when you go in
three-car garage converted into a
incredible like diorama Panorama 12d
it's not really
um uh model railroad uh capturing of the
Year 1956 on a line that's on a steady
incline from the Glendale Narrows part
of Los Angeles to Santa Barbara uh
including stops in Burbank and uh in the
Simi Valley and various places and
passes and uh Street Scenes and and uh
did we go with Glendale I forget if we
go to Glendale but in the Narrows
certainly
um I just words can't describe he spent
20 they have spent but mostly Bob spent
20 years designing
um tinkering with creating little
trees with in baking them by hand with
little orange trees because there's
still some agricultural scenes
in the valley
back then just a remarkable feat of
engineering of dedication of uh
Obsession from someone who like all good
libertarian policy analysts Advocates
heavily against uh foolish train
projects such as the ongoing High-Speed
Rail disaster in California among other
places and just loves trance loves loves
love strains and uh and it it's
remarkable if there's any way of those
some of you who are listening know Bob
um I would find find yourself in Fort
Lauderdale if I get yourself to Miami
sweet talked man it's designed totally
for the space it'll never be seen
elsewhere you unless someone you know
pays 25 million dollars for a helicopter
and just moves it somewhere uh it's not
going to be shown in the museum it is
Museum caliber it's still not finished
but it's getting close
um just re remarkable very moving like
American ingenuity full card at its best
I love it Nick have you ever seen the uh
the situation I saw an earlier iteration
of it when uh Bob and Lou lived in uh
Los Angeles yeah uh in the uh early to
mid 90s uh in a house that uh Mr William
Shatner who you may have heard of used
to own how's the swimming pool speaking
of Shatner yeah no you know I think
drain filled with sand as a health
precaution it's not funny but it's yeah
that's where we are right now um anyways
uh shout out to Bob and uh and uh and
and and uh you know Ingenuity art and
stick-to-itiveness
it's beautiful Catherine do you want to
express your sadness that you've made
bad decisions in your life
I don't want the podcasters to hear me
cry fair enough all right uh if you like
uh things that we do here at reason go
to reason.com donate uh see all of our
podcasts including the recent interview
with Nick Gillespie at reason.com
Pockets Nick do you got some live ones
coming up anytime soon some speakeasies
uh yeah we do actually on November 3rd
uh we're gonna have the great art
designer and graphic designer Steve
Heller who wrote A Memoir called growing
up underground a history of
counterculture New York this is a guy
who started with the Free Press New York
Free Press and screw magazine in the
late 60s and then devolved into working
for the New York Times and teaching at
the school for visual arts uh but he's a
major uh a major figure in what art
particularly counterculture art and
magazines uh looked like but we're going
to be talking to him at November 3rd and
this week on the reason interview it's
uh live yeah it's a live interview we
recorded with Richard Reeves the author
of a voice and man a great book from uh
the Brookings institution scholar
beautiful thank you for that and thank
you for listening send us your uh your
uh emails they've been uh great and
interesting and thought-provoking
Roundtable reason.com okay goodbye
[Music]